welcome to the live stream it has been a
very long time I don't even know how
long it's been since the last livestream
but things have been insane since the
last livestream I've been to northern
rural Indiana and come back I have what
else has happened since the last
livestream we have been targeted by
online troll Mike Serna vich who's now
trying to get me fired from my job as an
adjunct professor at Boston College we
have seen a Democrat win an Alabama
Senate race for the first time in
roughly 25 years we've had our Amazon
affiliate link cut although I don't know
if that happened before after the last
livestream now but it's been a while
it's been a while and there have been so
many new projects unfortunately now I
think I'm going to be able to get back
to more regular live streaming what
would the wrapping up of the winter
semester at Boston College and being
back in town other than the upcoming end
of the year we're gonna be off we'll be
on a staff vacation staff break but I
hope to be able to do more live
streaming because there is just so much
to talk about since it's been so long
since the last livestream let's just
refresh how these things work the great
thing about these is that they're live
so unless you're watching a replay which
you might be if it's not 8 p.m. Eastern
on December 13 2017 it's live so you can
participate best ways to participate
number 1 use super chat that's the
dollar sign at the bottom of the YouTube
chat window number 2 you stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show and what
happens when you super chat and you'll
see that animation because Victor
Savelle just did it for 5 bucks your
name will show up up here and a little
animation will play down here and that
happens with super chat and with stream
Labs ok questions comments I will get to
them I will answer them all comments and
questions welcome number 3 new members
and patrons will get live thank-yous if
you sign up for a membership at david
pakman.com slash membership during the
stream
if you make a pledge on patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
during the stream I will thank you and
sing your praises and I have there's
actually big news with patreon I don't
know how many of you have been following
the patreon drama over the last five or
six days but there is big news and I'll
talk about that and we're also accepting
cryptocurrency now you can go to david
pakman.com slash cryptocurrency and it
will have information about how to
contribute via the three biggest crypto
currencies if you don't know how to get
cryptocurrency there's also information
about that and you can get yourself ten
bucks for free and get us 10 bucks for
free when you make an account with
coinbase and please don't troll
there are moderators monitoring the
YouTube chat they've been fully
deputized and empowered by me to get rid
of the obvious trolling we just we
there's just no place for it there
really isn't people are here to have fun
people are here to participate people
are here to do all sorts of really great
things other than obvious trolling so
please none of that okay so where to
begin first and foremost I am now be
targeted by Mike Serna vich okay Mike
Serna vich is this I I don't even really
know what his formal title is I call him
just a troll I think he's like a guy
with a big Twitter following and I think
he wrote articles somewhere at some
point he targeted our friend Sam cedar
from the majority report a couple of
weeks ago and based on a satirical tweet
from 2009 that Sam sent Mike Serna vich
and his followers started a campaign to
get Sam cedar fired from MSNBC as a
contributor which originally worked but
MSNBC ultimately saw through and saw
sort of like the cynical objectives of
that campaign and they rehired Sam cedar
also started an attempt to try to get
advertisers to pull their ads from Sam's
show which my understanding is has not
happened I think that they've basically
failed on both now I did a couple of
videos defending Sam and apparently that
put me on the Rae
of Mike Serna vich because last night
when I made a tweet about the Alabama
election I jokingly but truthfully said
about the political situation in Alabama
something along the lines of and I'm
going off the top of my head something
like when it's all said and done no
matter who wins or loses tonight the
voters of Alabama are going to have to
reckon with the reality that they live
in Alabama now Mike Serna vich and his
followers immediately started attacking
me as if I was saying something about
the people of Alabama but of course I
wasn't I was saying Alabama as a state
has been ravaged and is a disaster it's
one of the poorest states terrible
education terrible access to health care
it's a real disaster and my point was
whether Doug Jones or Roy Moore won last
night Alabama for the foreseeable future
is still going to be a really bad place
to be from those particular points of
view doesn't mean you don't love Alabama
doesn't mean you don't have friends and
family in Alabama whatever and in any
case these Serna vich followers went
bonkers and they've started both
tweeting to and emailing Boston College
demanding that I be fired and I've not
heard anything from Boston College I was
super upfront with them I said listen
this is this is happening I'm being
attacked by this person here's what I
said I've not deleted the tweets I'm not
making any effort to hide the tweets
this this is what they did to Sam cedar
they fortunately failed and that's
what's going on and it'll absolutely be
their call as to whether there are or
aren't any repercussions and and I hope
that that there are not obviously but
yes I am under attack by Mike Serna
[ __ ] so that is going on we also have
as I mentioned a Democrat well when he's
seated and that may not be until January
as we'll talk about on tomorrow's show
we have a Democrat who is going to be
representing Alabama in the United
States Senate Doug Jones defeated Roy
Moore and my number one takeaway I know
that there have been all sorts of
everybody's trying to give their hot
take about the Roy Moore loss in Alabama
my main thing is everybody saying
Republicans did the right thing
Republicans couldn't bring themselves to
vote for ROI more mostly they voted for
Roy Moore right so the idea that Alabama
that serial allegations of child sex
assault were too much for Alabama
Republicans that's not true
most Alabama Republicans voted for Roy
Moore there was a small fraction of
Alabama Republicans combined with a
strong turnout from black Alabamians who
voted by a 93 and 98 percent men and
women respectively margin for Doug Jones
that's why Roy Moore lost not because
Alabama Republicans had some great as
I've been calling it a come-to-jesus
moment not a term I normally use and
completely rejected the ideology of Roy
Moore now most of them said yeah we're
fine with Roy Moore and we don't even
care about the serial child sex assault
allegations so that that is that is my
big takeaway everything else has sort of
been said I don't know that I need to
really repeat too much else so that is
what's going on as far as Roy Moore as
far as what's going on with patreon
there has been jeg antic drama with
patreon over the last five days if
you're if just to catch you up right
patreon is this platform we use it to
raise money on the show at the end of
November we had reached very close to
2,200 patrons and it was really going
well and as you can see at the bottom
left of this image
it says twenty twenty-one of twenty to
fifty patrons we've decided that when we
get to 20 250 patrons we'll be producing
a twelve part miniseries on critical
thinking tomorrow on the show I will
have a preview of some of the graphics
that we've already started to put
together for that miniseries it's gonna
be absolutely tremendous but you'll
notice that we have fallen very far from
2,200 patrons why did this happen well
about five days ago patreon rolled out a
new
fee policy and what that fee policy
outline in short was that some of the
fees that previously came out of my cut
of the of the contributions we're going
to be added to your pledge in other
words if you were pledging $5 you might
end up actually being charged $5 plus
something because you'd be paying
additional funds for some of those
patreon fees now the truth is that in
the net it was going to be good for the
creators right but that doesn't really
matter the way that the policy was
announced and structured was an absolute
disaster the truth is it should be my
call
whether it's worth fund raising based on
what the net of a donation is going to
be putting this sort of front and center
for donors was a strategic mistake
particularly because donors don't
necessarily know well here's how much of
a fee I'm paying here versus what might
David be paying on other platforms so I
think it was an absolute and total
disaster and as you can see we lost
close to 200 patrons okay and when
you're talking about an average pledge
of $4 in some change a month that's a
lot of money for us and I've been
telling people listen I respect your
decision not to pledge on patreon but
just so you know when you just cancel
the pledge you were also punishing us
and if your intent is to contribute to
the David Pakman show
then maybe consider moving your support
from patreon to membership where we pay
30 cents plus 2.9 percent as a fee or
some other method of contribution well
the good news is that this has been such
an utter and total disaster for patreon
that they have reached out to both
existing patrons as well as all creators
and they've told us we're not going to
do it we're not going to do it we are
going to can't we're canceling that idea
we're canceling the new fee structure
we're going back to the old structure we
are sorry so that's the good news
the bad news is that you know when
there's like an article in the newspaper
with some horrible and inaccuracy and
everybody sees it and talks about it for
five days and then on day six on page
twelve the newspaper prints a little
correction and nobody sees the
correction that's what's going on now
all of the people who cancelled their
pledges on patreon the nearly 200 of you
they no longer are getting patreon
mailing list so they will have no idea
that this changed so anyway please
spread the word if you're listening and
you cancel the pledge because of the fee
change I I'm asking you to reconsider
that Andry pledge and if you do it
tonight while while we are streaming at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
will thank you
and I will sing your praises and listen
we've got this critical thinking
miniseries to look forward to which is
one of the most ambitious and I think
best things that we have ever worked on
and the work that's going on going into
it past staffers have worked on it
producer Noah Ferguson is working on it
now it is a really exciting project and
and I hope people will pledge because
they value it and I will talk talk more
about that probably on tomorrow's
program okay so that's the latest with
patreon they made the right decision
ultimately the problem is that it's
gonna be probably too late for some
people to even be made aware of it which
is which is sad let's dig into the super
chats a little bit super chat is the
dollar sign at the bottom of the chat
window Victor Savelle cent to $5 super
chat bit off-topic but very important do
you think net neutrality has a chance
still from my understanding there is
still a judge who has to rule I never
want to just say it it's over until it's
actually over we spoke to attorney
Andrew Torres last week or the week
before and he said listen net net
neutrality is going the question is in
what other ways can we try to once that
happens reinstate some of the provisions
but you're right Victor until it's over
it's not over and I say keep calling
your elected officials because until
until it's over you can still try to
lobby them Andrew Schreiber has sent the
$10 super chat love what you do
well thanks very much Andrew I
appreciate it and really appreciate your
contribution today thank you
Elle Morris has sent a $2 hug Sameach
thank you so much L it is day two of
Hanukkah tonight and I am doing nothing
for it I'm live streaming that's
basically it but very very lovely time
of year the festival of lights Andrea
Morgan with a $5 super chat progressives
need to stick together keep up the good
work I agree and it's not happening it's
not happening I did a story on Monday
and you can check it out on the YouTube
channel about this I'm Kai I don't
really have a good term for it but I'm
calling it like a Leninist strain of the
left that loves Hugo Chavez and Nicolas
Maduro hates Israel and loves Putin and
Russia and I and I think it's hugely
problematic and I wish that that we
could get progressives on the same page
that they aren't right now but hey Trump
is helping to push progressives together
at least to some degree
Jamal Swift has sent the $10 super Chad
does do you see any similarities between
Republicans today and the Reichstag in
Hitler's pre-war Germany I want to be
really careful with this Jamal because
anytime we start saying X's like the
Nazis or Y is like Hitler
you're starting to tread on sort of
dicey territory particularly if it's not
completely accurate the way I like to
say it is that we are seeing
authoritarian tendencies from the Trump
administration today to those similar
tendencies to those that existed in pre
World War two Europe okay I think that
that's a better way to say it than to
necessarily draw an analogy to Hitler a
Jordan Barnard has sent the $5 superjet
any updates on the war on drugs long
form peace I suggested it on a live
stream back in September also when are
you debating sargon of akkad
peace and love okay two questions here
glad to answer both no update on war on
drugs we have a list right now and
fact it's just a friendly live stream
why don't I even pull up the list of
what we're working on right now and
there is a lot that is for sure
long-form video ideas here it is so
here's what here's what we're currently
working on right we the most recent
long-form piece was the race an IQ piece
right now we have the critical thinking
miniseries that is in production
actively in production that will be
released in pieces once we hit 2250
patrons okay so that's going on number
one number two I have this idea for a
video called maybe Godwin's law and it
will be actually related to the last
Super Jack question when can we say
something is like the Nazis I think that
that's an interesting idea a
cryptocurrency long-form explainer what
is cryptocurrency where does it derive
its value how can you purchase
cryptocurrency how is it different or
similar to buying other types of
securities is there a bubble
what is blockchain all of that type of
stuff that's an interesting idea the war
on drugs is on our list in no particular
order by the way how white nationalism
gets normalized I think that that would
be an interesting piece and then we also
have a piece on universal health care
that's kind of been kicking around for a
little bit
that a prior intern sort of outlined for
us and we just never had the time to
move forward on it so that's what's on
the list right now Jordan and updates as
as I have them when am i debating sargon
of akkad
yeah so the the drunken peasants have
been trying or were trying to organize a
debate between me and sargon of akkad
I heard from TJ Kirk known to some of
you these as the amazing atheist we went
back and forth a little bit about
duration timing and topics and the most
recent thing was I responded with some
thoughts on the topics TJ had suggested
like for example one of the topics was
brexit that he suggested I'm not an
expert on brexit III the last person
that should be debating anyone on brexit
is me I've done a few stories about it
I'm not an expert I'm not passionate
about brexit so I was trying to
fine-tune the topics and then I never
heard back
and in fact I heard from him last let me
see if I can look in my email it's been
almost a month to the day November 14th
he wrote to me I wrote back and then he
did not respond again so I don't know if
they've lost interest or they they're
seeing me as difficult because I'm not
acquiescing to their demands I don't
know but that's where things stand
Mexicano TV has sent a $2.00 super chat
how do you keep a straight face talking
to Jesse Lee Peterson I'm so
desensitized to that type of insanity
that it's really not difficult it's
pretty easy for me to keep a straight
face let's go over to stream labs you
can contribute at stream labs.com slash
the David Pakman show
your name will show up up here when you
do that just like with a super chat
let's start with aquatic Borealis who
said with a $20.00 stream lapse
contribution thank you can you address
the issue of transparent voting in
Congress and the wait has opened up
elected representatives to ensure to
pressure from lobbyists special interest
groups internal party pressure etc
reference Congressional Research org
yeah so that there's an argument to be
made that the fact that all votes in
Congress are public is actually
counterproductive because although we
know how each elected official voted
they now can be held to account if they
don't vote the way lobbyists or donors
want them to vote it is a double-edged
sword though aquatic Borealis because if
you make voting not transparent in
Congress you are losing a certain degree
of ability to hold your elected
officials accountable in terms of what
policies they're trying to further so
it's a double-edged sword I think it's
an interesting question that you bring
up it's a problem I don't have an answer
to it unfortunately David Moss has sent
a $2 stream labs contribution do you
think liberal youtubers should boost
each other up like how steven crowder
constant
interviews other conservatives this
seems to grow a community of like-minded
folks seems to help out true
conservatives like Dave Rubin
oops classical liberal I mean yeah
listen I it's tough we're all so busy
and yeah it's true steven crowder is
doing a much better job of sort of
growing this progressive conservative
ecosystem then i think some of the
progressive youtubers are doing on
youtube i would be glad to do that one
thing i did do and i don't know if
people are aware of this but it is a
very very exciting thing the david
pakman show is now publishing our
content on a platform called steam it
which is st double e MIT and i joined
that about a month ago and financially
it has been really a very good thing for
the program which has been hit so hard
with YouTube D monetization losing our
Amazon affiliate link Mike Serna vich is
now trying to get me fired from Boston
College so anyway we joined steam at St
double e MIT and started posting content
there and so far it's going pretty well
today I recruited Sam cedar from the
majority report and he has now joined
steam it and the awesome thing about it
is that I can support Sam financially
and he can support me merely by upvoting
each other's content without having to
actually spend any money because it's a
blockchain based platform and that's one
area where we can directly support each
other in a number of ways and by the way
if you haven't checked that out I did
put a link to this in the description
for the live stream you can refresh the
URL is steam it comm slash at David
Pakman and you can join and please
follow me and the great thing about it
is you don't have to invest any money
just by building reputation points on
the platform and then up voting my
content you are helping to support the
work that I'm doing so it's it's a it's
a really great thing I don't know what
the future of the platform is in the
same way that I don't know what the
future of any crypto currency or
blockchain based platform is but so far
it has been a really really good thing
so please check that out
and I do appreciate the support one
other thing I wanted to mention let me
see if I can send you guys a link to
something because I'm seeing Steven
Crowder's name came up and I hate it
when this happens because there is a
real big misunderstanding about YouTube
channels to some degree I want people to
go to let me see here where are we now
you know what I can't pull it up in any
case the point is when people start
talking about comparing YouTube channels
what channel is doing well what channel
is not doing well go to socialblade and
actually compare the views on different
channels because what you will often
find is that a channel might have a lot
of subscribers but not necessarily a lot
of views and views really is how you get
the message out right so I think that
that's just a an important thing for us
to keep in mind okay that is it for
stream labs questions and comments so
far a stream labs comm slash the David
Pakman show
back over here on super chat Titan bait
has sent a $5 super chat asking if
single-payer health care was implemented
what would happen to the workers in
those companies I was asked this and
wasn't sure how to answer which
companies I don't know if you're talking
about insurance companies or people that
work at hospitals doing medical billing
it's a different answer for each if
you're asking about people working at
health insurance companies some of them
are going to lose their jobs some of
those some of those people are going to
lose their jobs and that's something
that we have to contend with
it is not imagine not having developed
the automobile in order to prevent horse
buggy drivers from losing their jobs it
sounds insane today right and given the
ability to drastically improve our
health care system in the way that
single payer would we are going to have
to just accept that people are going to
lose their jobs that work at health
insurance companies some of the people
some people not everybody because
private insurance would still be allowed
if people wanted it and those people are
going to have to find other jobs and
they may be unemployed for some Trott
sometime and this is something that
happens is it's the same thing that's
going on with coal workers right should
we should we boost up coal artificially
so the
coworkers don't lose their jobs even
though it's a hugely damaging and
economically counterproductive
technology obviously nots an idiotic
argument economically to suggest that a
big picture and sort of at the
macroeconomic level let me do a few
thank-yous because we are starting to
get some different contributions on
patreon
I want to thank Joaquin Stewart who has
pledged five dollars a month and also
richard rosario who has made a pledge as
well and it just went off my screen I
believe it was also five or ten dollars
per month the big news is that patreon
has decided to reverse their decision to
increase the amount of pledge fees paid
by the donors they've reversed that
because of outcry from our viewers and
the viewers of so many other independent
program so please if you have canceled
your patreon pledge as a result of that
over the last few days please resume
your support because that has that is no
longer happening the fees are staying as
they were and we do want to get back the
200 or so patrons that we lost over on
the membership side membership
continuing to be our biggest source of
revenue you have a coupon code that's
available it'll drop a $6 a month
membership to just three dollars and 60
cents you get the bonus show the
commercial free all-access pass the
coupon code is I vote at 17 I want to
send a big thank you to John reach who
has just signed up for membership I want
to send a gigantic thank you to Robert
Hamilton who is a new member raquel
lanes is a new member at david
pakman.com slash membership and agnes
Farkas has signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership thank you to all of you
and the one other thing that I do want
to show you let me see if I can add this
because this is something i i've not
streamed for so long that i have not
even been able to show you this so far
we do have the 2018 david pakman show
calendar now
available let me see how I can do this
just so it'll look right okay it's kind
of over the patreon thing but you get
the idea every year for the last one two
three I think for years we have done a
David Pakman show
calendar the calendar is all made up of
a David Pakman show audience created art
so all of the artwork inside the
calendar is from in this case it is
three different
David Pakman show viewers there are
original comic books in it
comic strips in it there are sort of
other types of images and you can get
these calendars for free if you want
with a membership at david pakman.com
slash calendar 18 just one example of a
comic strip that you will get in this
fantastic fantastic calendar is right
there this is me with a beard and this
is just one of the comic strips that is
in the calendar this is a really really
good calendar and I hope that you will
get it and you can go to david
pakman.com slash calendar 18 you can buy
just the calendar you can also get the
calendar autographed or not a DeGraff so
that's really cool we've already sold my
target is 250 we've got about 70 already
ordered which is awesome
okay so check that out we do have some
other questions and comments to get to
here dragons eenz dragons ends not sure
how to pronounce that has sent a $5
super chat in either the short or long
term can anything be done to stop or
reverse the impending tax plan which
hurts middle and lower class americans
okay
so i don't believe that the tax plans
passage is sort of a fait accompli
there's a couple different things that
could get in the way of the tax plan
number one democrats are trying to hold
up the vote if Republicans will not seat
doug jones until january Democrats are
pushing for the tax plan to not be voted
on until Jay
don't think it's going to happen I think
that the vote is going to happen now
there is a possibility that more
moderate Republican senators like Susan
Collins Lisa Murkowski Jeff Flake Ron
Johnson is considering not voting for
the bill they may torpedo the thing and
this is why if we were able to get a
delay on the vote until doug jones is
seated
that's one more republican you don't
need to flip in order to block the bill
so i this is a tax plan that is very
unpopular i do not believe that its
passage is guaranteed at this time and
what you can do is keep calling your
elected officials because that is going
to be it still does make a difference it
still does make a difference
i'm noticing a couple people in the chat
talking about Senator John McCain being
hospitalized he has been hospitalized it
is it is for the side effects of his
cancer treatment okay he's been
hospitalized at Walter Reed Medical
Center and it's being described right
now as normal side effects of his cancer
therapy according to his office as of
just a couple hours ago if that and he
plans to get back to the Senate as soon
as possible I actually saw a really
interesting interview today
I don't watch this daytime television
program called the view Megan McCain
John McCain's daughter is one of the
co-hosts of it but today I did catch on
YouTube a clip of Joe Biden whose son
died of the exact type of cancer that
John McCain has talking to and really
trying to comfort Megan McCain and I
really just see Joe Biden as a good guy
I'm not saying I necessarily agree or
disagree with him on any particular
policy position but it was a really
interesting clip and I encourage you to
check it out and you know we wish the
best for for John McCain a frank
macwrite with a $20 super check there
are conflicting stories of how Omarosa
Manigault idol was director of
communications for the office of public
liaison what are those duties
what was that who was in that role under
about Obama no idea and no idea I don't
even I saw some the I bookmarked the
story Frank and then I realized I don't
really care about
Omarosa that the entire hiring of
Omarosa to begin with was was bizarre to
me it's sort of like reality show
presidency which is exactly what we have
so I don't know I'm gonna look at that
and if it's if it seems interesting I I
might cover it on the program tomorrow
so I wish I had more of an answer Frank
but I I don't and I won't pretend that I
do
Jordan Bern Barnard has sent a $2 super
Chad Ajit PI is scum net neutrality vote
coming soon yeah it's it's sad I mean I
because I think that net neutrality is
going to go I think that it's it's not
going to be around too much longer and
it will be we're gonna have to rebuild
as far as that goes but yeah you know
earlier we had a question about is there
any chance at all that we could keep net
neutrality I don't see it happening in
its current iteration I think it's gonna
go and then we'll have to look at
potentially rebuilding it let me say
thank you to a couple new David Pakman
show members they are starting to fly in
Justin Lowe thank you thank you for
signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership you have the 40% discount
code available if you want it a couple
of other new members I want to say
thanks to Angelo Robinson Angelo
Robinson has signed up while we've been
chatting here
Jason Costello has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership and diane
sureiy i'm not exactly sure how the last
name is pronounced char a or sure a
diane i'm sure of has also signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership thank
you thank you it has been quite a ride
this year between youtube dee
monetization and the recent patreon
kerfuffle having our amazon link cut
mike Serna vich trying to get me fired
from boston college where I'm an adjunct
professor it's been difficult and
everybody's support has really
and a great great thing and on that note
one of the things that we are doing
because of your support is continuing to
create new content new content including
things like the twelve part twelve or so
part critical thinking miniseries which
I will be previewing the introduction
for on tomorrow's episode of the David
Pakman show that's it for today's live
stream got to cut this one short a lot
of work to do on tomorrow's program
check out the calendars that are
available at david pakman.com slash
calendar 18 we will send them anywhere
in the world even to those military APO
addresses we do have members of the
military who watch the show I will
stream again soon now that things have
settled down a little bit